hello Berlin how is everyone it's an
absolute pleasure to be on this stage as
Sarah said I've been coming to J's comp
for years and I'm so privileged and
pleasure to be back on this stage and to
give back to the community very sad that
I'm not here with my family because to
me also coming back to Jay's comp every
time feels like coming back to see my
family and I think that's because of the
amazing community we have built here in
the organizers built so I can I also get
a massive run opposed to the organizers
for allowing us all to be here to do
this so my name is Patrick Hammond you
can catch me on the on the Twitter's and
on the across the internet at Patrick
coming and I work for the edge cloud
provider fastly where we specialize in
real-time content delivery for the
world's leading brands and there I get a
lot of time to sit and think about and
research how we can make our customers
websites load as fast as possible and
that's what I'm here to talk to you
about today so why am I actually here
and what does the clickbait e BuzzFeed
Head headline of to push or not to push
even means I'm not certainly not going
to recite Hamlet to you now and the
reason we're here is because of this I
hear this all the time in fact I've sat
on stages like this and said exactly
this that hb2 is going to solve this
problem it's going to prove self open X
or Y literally everyone and the problem
is is it's not resource loading in the
browser is very very hard and hopefully
after this talk you have a better
understanding of why it's hard but some
of the techniques that we have in our
toolbox today to overcome some of the
problems that is introduced and why is
it hard it's because performance is
tightly coupled to latency the speed of
light is not going to get any faster
connection costs are high TCP handshake
and round-trip times aren't going to go
away TCP congestion control algorithm is
there for very very good reasons but it
penalizes us at the beginning of a
connection when it's most important our
critical resources can be hidden to the
browser's Browder's are extremely
powerful things and how speculative
passes but they simply are not magic
enough to know the resources that you as
an application developer want to load
and because of that bandwidth is often
underutilized we leave idle connections
we could be sending resources but we
just simply can't do that yet because of
the way that browsers and servers
interact with each other and finally
once we do get it down script especially
for the reason why a lot of us are here
as JavaScript developers is extremely
expensive to parse and execute and we
waste idle time on the network again
because of that and so how can we load
our resources most efficiently and what
patterns and techniques can we use today
and what's coming up in the future
that's going to enable us to do this in
the most efficient in the speedy way so
first I want us to do a fort exercise
think about the product or the website
that you're designing today and if you
were only allowed to send three Ross
resources down the wire what would they
be
is it your font is it the lazy loaded
related comments at the back on the
bottom of this ft.com homepage or that
adverts no I don't think so
what did the user actually come here for
and that's what you need to be thinking
about Ben Schwartz my dear friend from
caliber who's actually sitting here with
us today he creates this - we took a lot
of the time when we're talking about
loading we talked about the critical
quest path or a critical request and he
defines a critical request is one that
contains an asset this is essential to
the content within the users viewport
and so what are your critical resources
have that exercise I want you really to
take this away from my talk because I
want you to think about what are the two
or three things that you need to send
down as soon as possible
so that the browser can get on with
rendering and creating a good user
experience for your users
is it the critical CSS for your initial
route is it your fonts your hero images
one thing that we don't discuss enough
is that application bootstrap data a lot
of server-side single series client-side
rendered applications probably make a
Jason request that's hidden to the
browser it's known as a hidden sub
resource and the browser doesn't know
about it upfront we need to be able to
tell the browser what the resources
specifically to our need and for to
create delightful users experiences and
so once you've determined what your I am
your critical requests are you need to
think about how they contribute to the
user's experience after all performance
is a user experience problem what
resources do you need to get a first
meaningful paint what resources do you
have to deliver so that users can start
interacting with your website as fast as
possible and it's this section here that
we're going to focus on today this
initial loading experience and how we
can tell the browser give it make the
allow the browser to make informed
decisions about what it loads so that we
can have delightful users experience so
I summarized a good loading strategy as
one that prioritizes above-the-fold
rendering prioritizes interactivity it's
easy to use because some of them that
we're going to look at today aren't
necessarily and most importantly is
measurable the first solution to
overcoming a performance problem is to
measure your current performance and
then optimize for it so the first
technique that we've done now that we've
identified what we should be loading
let's see how we can do this efficiently
and the first technique I'm going to
discuss is the preload API what if we
could tell the browser ahead of time
what the critical resources are required
for this and now the problem is we
earlier wrongly identified fonts and
application bootstrap data as being
critical resources however they're
hidden from the browser and why is this
first you make a get request for the
home page we wait for the response for
that HTML amazing specification it can
be parsed incrementally so as the bytes
come down the wire the browser can start
constructing the Dom without having to
wait for the whole HTML file to be
delivered once it does that browsers
have this amazing thing called
speculative passes or pre passes that it
goes ahead whilst it's constructing the
Dom and finds all of your style sheets
or your script tabs referencing the page
and then actually initiates fetches for
them ahead of time but with CSS
unfortunately its render blocking and it
can't be parsed incrementally we have to
wait for all of the bytes to come down
first because if we didn't we'd like
cause lots of painting flashing on the
screen because due to the way the
Cascade works and so eventually it's
only until this point that the CSS
object model and the document object
model are combined to form what's known
as the render tree and it's only at this
point when we have a render tree and
we've done all of this networking first
is when the browser will dispatch the
front request because your CSS may
reference five or six front files but
actually only two of them are being used
for that initial load and this is why
fonts unknown as criticals hidden sub
resources the browser can't know about
them upfront so the idea behind preload
was what if we could provide a
declarative
faites primitive that initiates an early
fetch and separates fetching from
resource execution decoupling that logic
saying to the browser I know you're
gonna find the font later on and I know
you need it or for your JavaScript
application I know I'm going to make a
request for a jason a file about the
user you're not going to find it till
much later in the process but I know
about it here go and perform the
networking for it now and that's why
it's extremely powerful and here we now
have three new primitives one via HTML
one via JavaScript and the other my
preferred method via HTTP link headers
we also now very very recently also have
the module preload specification for
those of you that are shipping native
modules in the browsers already you can
do that fonts have to be requested as
cross-origin because there are non
credentialed resources so this is really
powerful just by adding three HTTP
headers we can tell the browser upfront
about all of our critical resources so
we were to look at the network waterfall
for ft.com for instance before applying
this you'll see that the font files are
really low priority here and because
they haven't been discovered until the
CSS file has been parsed but just by
adding the preload headers we can
instantly prioritize and initiate those
fetches early and so the browser can get
on with it
fastly customer certified Shopify sorry
and saw that they have 50% 1.2 seconds
improvement on their time to text
payment just by adding preload headers
for their font files and their critical
hidden sub resources I've been in the
performance industry for a very long
time and I've never known a single
technique that's one line of code that
can have a two-second average
improvement on on the user experience of
loading that page but the question that
I want to ask and propose to you is is
indicating resource hints via the HTML
like this in fact too late in the
connection flow too late in the loading
experience of the page and that's what
HB to server push comes in was
specifically was designed to solve and
so let's look at how it can help us
first let's look at the traditional
request flow that you make when you're
loading a page you perform a get request
to your server the server then has some
server think time it has to go and
perform a database action or render some
templates all of the time this is
thinking and then eventually it will
respond with your index dot HTML
especially if you've got a server
rendered application like this then the
browser starts pausing it it finds the
CSS file but this makes me quite sad
because we've left the connection open
for so long whilst the browser would the
server was doing that think time firstly
we see an average server think time to
between 200 and 400 milliseconds that
we've wasted on the wire here and
round-trip time could be anything
between 800 to a thousand milliseconds
on a good 3G connection so what if the
server could predict the next thing that
they serve that the client is going to
request is that main dot CSS file and it
could flush all the bytes through it
down as soon as it receives that get
requests and you're probably wondering
how can I use push if you have a hb2
server enabled today most of them are
Apache nginx iis node natively supports
it we can do this we've in the industry
we've converged upon using our dear
friend the link preload header to use as
the semantics of I want to push this
resource so if your server is h2 enabled
all it will do is read these and it will
initiate two pushes for you really super
quick win if you don't want to push and
you still want the semantics of preload
you can add the no push attribute there
and that first thing we also realize
that you probably might want to only
push and not have a race condition
between push and preload and so we allow
you to only say that and we'll strip the
header on the way out but what benefit
does is actually give us if we will look
to a common waterfall for loading a page
we've got the index file then we look
for the CSS we find that then we perform
that up the networking for the
JavaScript and the CSS by pushing the
resource we're saving one round-trip
here the light shaded bit the round-trip
time is the time it takes for the client
to send the request to an to hit the
server and back again until we start
receiving the first bytes and again on a
free G connection in Europe that
round-trip turn could be about 800
milliseconds in
and other developing areas that could be
seconds and so it's great it gives us a
one round-trip time saving to improve
our loading experience but notice here
this idle time still left on the
connection and this makes me really
really sad why is this let's let's look
again at this request flow as a server
push is indicated via the link header we
have to wait for the server to do its
think time and responding before we as a
server or your proxy layer you'll see
the N or if you use something like
Apache or nginx to balance between
application layer it's only until we've
received all of the HTML bytes will
initiate that push and that's far too
late in the connection flow because
we've still got that idle connection
time and this makes me really sad but
wasn't this what that what pushed was
designed to solve
so to summarize which gives us a run
round-trip saving use of server long
think times that my I would argue the
fact that if you need you have what that
long server think time you should be
optimizing your servers instead but is
linked header indication far too late in
the connection flow and this is where
async push released that fastly we call
it a Singh pitch comes in and to be able
to truly utilize push we need to de
couple the pushing behavior from our
applications HTML response and and do it
right the beginning of the connection
flow so a more common architecture as I
discussed that you may have a CDN or a
proxy sitting in front of your
application server as it receives that
request is the only there and then
whilst we have that server think time we
can push all of the bytes down the wire
and I forgot to mention earlier on the
way that push actually works is hb2 has
a binary data framing layer this is this
is a magical thing that it allows us to
no longer is it just plain text on the
wire on our TCP connection now we have
binary frames but that allows us to
interleave separate data frames for
subsequent requests or multiple requests
at the same time which is called
multiplexing this is why we can have a
single hb2 connection open and delivers
hundreds of resources at the same time
and so push works by sending a push
promise frame as you can see here and
this is a data frame tent and the wire
to the client saying I promise I'm going
to send you these bytes and here they
are go and have them
and so utilizing the idle connection
time like this makes me extremely happy
and again you're probably wondering how
you can do this so this is just using
nodes standard hates to be to standard
library I've got a request handler here
I check to see if it's the URL matches
if it does and like okay I want to
initiate a push and here is when you can
flush down your critical resources that
you've identified piping them down a
stream and then you can go and perform
your database lookups and your expensive
server think time and so let's see the
benefits that this has on our waterfall
as you can see here when I push example
yes we had the one round-trip saving
when we're using the link header by
using async push we've hit that Holy
Grail that we're pushing all of the
styles or JavaScript required to render
the screen before the HTML is even
consumed so now we have the browser has
all of the information it needs to
instantly render as soon as the HTML
finish and that makes Patrick extremely
happy but what about the repeat view I
hear you asking I mean I definitely ask
this a lot we've already sent their
assets to the client and surely if
you're applying good cache control
directives that the client should have
that asset in its cache but the problem
is is that we've got no way of
indicating to the server what is in its
cache so what actually is going to
happen is it on the repeat view we still
push and actually we've been detrimental
here and we could potentially create
contention on the underlying network
link and end up being worse then when
you didn't push at all and fastly in
fact we've definitely been seeing this
and my peers at Google have also said
that the majority of the time we're
actually seeing push to be caused as a
relation as a performance technique
instead of an improvement one solution
to this is the polymer team at Google
came up with a purple pattern and you
can only use this if you have a
progressive web application and the
serviceworker
you push all of your critical resources
the first time the page is loaded and
then you cache them in a serviceworker
and lazy load the rest and so the
subsequent requests the requests never
even goes out to the network and then
they can say we don't have to push so we
benefit from not having
to to worry about the cash date but
that's only if you have a service worker
and a lot of us in the room may not have
and so the server's got no knowledge of
the class date and this is a really
really big problem so what is the
problem right the theory there's braked
push should be amazing it should we
should be able to give the client all of
the information it needs before I've
even received the HTML but the adoption
is extremely low and why is that what's
the problem
in fact I also want to make a pop poll
here who is using h2 in production right
now and put leave your hands up if
you're also using push yeah so only
about 10% of the people that were using
push and there was only probably about
20% of the room that we're using h2 at
all so what is the problem why is no one
adopting it to do that let's take a look
at the request flow again once we've
sent the get request and we start
pushing the bytes down the wire I lie to
you earlier on is even though the the
browser doesn't have a mechanism for
telling its cache state it has a
mechanism to reset that stream and so
you can send a reset stream frame saying
I don't want those bikes anymore for
that I've already got it in my cache so
that should solve the problem but
unfortunately we've actually got a race
condition here that by the time the
client has initiated the reset stream
but by the time that gets to the server
because our critical resources are
normally quite small we've actually
flushed all of the bytes down the wire
already or if more importantly they've
probably left the user space of your out
server application that's inside their
TCP buffer and once something's in the
colonel's TCP space there's no way for
an application to prevent those bytes
from being flushed sound onto the
physical link so we've got a reset a
race condition here which really isn't a
good thing the new quic protocol that
was developed by Google is now going
through your ITF standardization is
going to hopefully solve a lot of those
problems by you by moving a lot of the
application layer out of the kernel into
user space and that's going to allow us
to do some amazing things here another
really common area of misconception or
misuse of hb2 server push is how the
server is actually cached that resource
and once I pushed all the bytes down
still a request
that's initiated from your page needs to
claim that resource from the hb2 s push
cache and a push cache is not connected
to the HTTP cache it's connected to the
lifetime of that single HTTP to
connection so for every h2 connection
you have to an origin you're also going
to have a dedicated push cache for that
but one of the problems is the push
press is actually the last cache to be
requested as the request leaves the page
first it will go to the memory cache
that's attached to that document it's a
all of the resources that that document
has already requested then it will be
looked looked up in the serviceworker
cache then the HTTP cache the
serviceworker castmates because are
shared globally where is the memory
customer's parent and finally it will it
will try and look inside the push cache
and so it's highly likely that a lot of
the time the push past will never be
claimed and therefore you've actually
wasted sending bytes down the wire and
created a detrimental experience in
contention on the network the other
tricky thing here to note is hb2
connections are credentialed or non
credentials and that's why a font file
as we've discussed before has to be
served as an as a non-pretentious
resource so if a CSS file was to push a
font file the CSS file is credentialed
and so it actually won't be able to
claim the font file request and so to
summarize the problem here is the push
custom answers if the connection has to
be Authority for it is a single cache
per connection the items can only be
claimed once so if you have multiple
tabs open for the single one then you
can what the push can only be sent once
you have to repeat that push and the
thing that I find that the most
interesting is that it's not Specht the
cache behavior is not specs as part of
the specification and so all of the
browser's implementations vary wildly
and so if you do consider using HP to
push I urge you to read this blog post
by Jake Archibald where he goes into
great detail about all of the browser
inconsistencies and the fact it is
actually a lot tougher than we thought
it was and and if you don't just the
TLDR summarization of that we can only
really stabili use push at the moment in
Chrome and Firefox Safari is completely
non-deterministic and how its pushing
works because the HP twos networking
stack is separate from Safari itself
it's I just inherits it from OSX and
edge have done some really great work
one of the good things that Jake did in
this post was to go and document
all the problems and create tickets on
all of their browsers bug trackers so my
hats off to Jake for doing that edge of
really improving but not not yet there's
still one connection per tag and no
fetch support so this leads us to having
to you a sniff for push and I think
that's really really bad and we all know
what happens when we start going down
that rude route of you a sniffing and
then lastly the rate of adoption I just
want you all to put up your hands for
instance at fastly we only see 0.008
requests so that's 800 requests out of a
million requests to do we do around 6
million requests a second that we see as
and push initiated if which was so good
every one which should be using it but
they're not and this lack of adoption
has got so bad that certain vendors have
considered even ripping push out to the
HP 2 specification entirely so the
question is when should you push only if
you have long round trip times only if
you have an app shell architecture and
you could use the purple pattern or for
instance if you could manage your own
cache date natively so if you've got a
native application or an electron app so
the question really is is that one
round-trip saving really worth the
complexity that the benefits it gives us
and are there simple solutions out there
that we can use and this is why lastly I
want to talk about what's ahead for us
in the future and I'm really excited
about what the near future holds up for
resource lazing in the browser
specifications so the first question is
can we just fix the HP to push problems
there's they're quite simple what can we
do to fix that and that's where the
cached digest specification comes in so
what if the browser whenever it created
a new connection could send a frame
called a cache digest that contained a
cuckoo filter which is a probabilistic
data structure representing all of the
items that the browser has for the cache
of that host name and then the server
can be much more intelligent about what
it wants to push it's like okay I'm not
going to push main dot CSS because I
know you have that in your patch but I
am going to send you that my new version
of my JavaScript application because you
you don't have the latest version of
that and I'm also really excited by not
just for solving push this opens up a
lot of great opportunity for us for
instance in the JavaScript bundling and
modules world that we could choose and
be more intelligent of what we bundle
what we
down if we have a bit more knowledge
about the client cache date and so going
back to the repeat view if we had past
digests for the our first view we could
push but then on the subsequent view the
client says no I've already got that in
my resource and we wouldn't have to push
it and that makes me really really happy
first I jest specification is an
experimental in ITF at the moment and it
was proposed by my colleague Kazuo and
it's been worked on by your advice at
Akamai but I think we're going to start
seeing implementations land in browsers
soon first you've already got the first
implementation of the server-side of
that in our open source hate to be -
server h2o but this all seems a bit too
complicated like we're still having to
maintain a lot of logic to manage state
between the client and the server HTTP
after rule is a state list protocol
right it's one of the why it's so
beautiful and it's a bit too complicated
and this is where the 103 early hints
specification comes in this again is
proposed by my colleague Kazuo at
firstly who has heard of 100
informational ranges at all I hadn't at
all until this came out and so one if
there is a new HD response code that
allows the server to indicate the to the
client the resources that are going to
be required for the next for that for
the 200 responses that's coming and it
looks like this when we perform a get
request we then send down an initial
response just containing headers using
our friend link rel preload and then the
browser gets to decide ok I've got this
I don't have that and initiate those
fetches early during that server think
time and this is what it would look like
on the wire so it's as simple as that
and that's why I think this is a lot
more powerful than push because we're
moving that logic and that decision
process back to the browser where it
belongs so the server can quickly send
down a 103 response saying here all the
critical resources for this page you
decide what you want to do with it and
then subsequently follow up with a 200
again this has been accepted by eight
ITF it's an experimental mode we've got
a working implementation at fast in the
server side but the problem is at the
moment many browser vendors are worried
about the complexity this adds to the
networking stack we're also worried
we're going to break the internet
because a lot of middle proxies don't
understand the 100 range so we'll only
be served over TLS to overcome that
problems so early hints gives us all of
the same benefits as push
it's much simpler and we can leverage
the browser cache now and not have the
complexities of the h2 server push cache
and just more importantly I think it's
great because it allows the client to do
the decision-making and finally we know
that we've got preload to do the headers
and a new specifications coming out core
priority hints that allows us as the
application developer to decorate our
HTML with resources are saying I know
this hero image is high priority but
this fetch request is low and are you oh
just going to check out the
specification and add to the to the
github page here
so in closing I've run out of time so
I've got to wrap up I'm afraid we've
only just scratched the surface here of
methodologies that I hope I've given you
some techniques that you can use today
hb2 doesn't solve everything but there
are a lot of things coming out to serve
this resource loading in the browser is
hard but I'm excited by the future but
most importantly performance is for
humans optimized for a good user
experience not for the networking stack
measure your experience and optimize for
that and so the checklist of what if I
was going to do today identify your
critical resources preload any hidden
sub resources avoid push where possible
and the future is looking great we can
decorate our HTML apriority hints and
use early hints when they come available
thank you very much
[Applause]